ξανά ισβάρως οποιο δήποτε δεν τον μιάζει ι πολιπες χώρες ακόμα και οι σύμμαχη του
δηλαδή ευρωπαϊκή ένωση και χώρες όπως είναι ι απονία ο καναδάστουμε εξικό που για πάρα
πολλά χρόνια είχαν εξαιρετικές εμπολικές σχέσης βεβαίως έχει μια μανία με την κίνα είναι ξεκάθαρο
είνο μεγάλο τουαντίπαλος το αντιπαλοδέως από την άλλη θέλει να να κάνει ντελίυβερ δηλαδή να
ν δώσει τους ρψηποφόρους αυτό που υποσχέθηκε και το μεγάλο πρόβλημα της ευρώπις αυτή τη
στιγμή ιδικότερα για την απμομιχανήπον ομάζετ γερμανία είναι πώς θα πιβιώσει τους δασμούμς γιατί εξάγει
περιπολύ περισσότερα η ευρώπια α όςαισάγι άρα το οτελικό αποτελεσμα οότελικό λογαριασμός είναι δεν συμπέρει
την ευρωπη και ειδικότερα με μια δύο μηχανεία που είναι γερασμένη και με προβλήματα διαρθοτικά
εδώ και δεκαϊτίες αυτό οι ιδασμή είναι ένατεράστιο πλήγμα θα πω επίησης ότι η επηρεάζει
και τη ψυχολογία όλον των πολιτώ δηλαδή ακόμα και στην κύπρο και το ζούμε και
θα τοζήσουμε περπολύ περισθώροης είμαστε μακριά από τον αζήσουμε και σαγκυπρια και αγόρα αυτές τις
εξαγγελίες αυτές τις εξαγγελίες σε οικονομικό επιπειδο νέ γιατί είμαστε μια μικρή οικονομία και ξααυτόμαστε
πολύ περισσότε έχουμε τη δύναμη που χεια μερικί τουλάχιστον για να πει ότι εγώ θα
από μονός ότι δική μου οικονομία και σιγάσει κά θα την κάνου μεγάλη ξανά όμως
βλέπουμε τη ψυχολογία του πολίτη ότι μέσω των εξαγγελιό κράμ και της συμπεριφοράς του πολιτικού
συστήμα ωστε να μερική πιρειάζεται και ναι πιο ακριες συμπεριφορές περισσότερο να βλέπειο καθένας το
δικό του παρά το συλλογικό καλό να βλέπουμε απλά το οικονομικό μας συμφέρο νομίζω θα
επηρεάσει και πάρα πολίτες εκλογές το ίκο ίκο ιεξει στην κύπρο πάρα πολύ υπάρχει μια
αντίδραση να ψηφίσεις κάτι περισσότερο με το συνέίστημα παρά μετηλογική νιόθεισότη το παλιό πολιτικό σκοινικό
πρέπει να ανατραπεί υπάες